regardez d'abord eric zemmour qui est
interrogé pour la première fois en
direct sur cette une de paris match
c'est ce matin sur sud radio
j'étais journaliste en 1988 pendant la
campagne de françois mitterrand il y
avait une de ces jeunes maîtresses
suédoise qui était journaliste et qui
d'ailleurs était enceinte de lui je n'ai
jamais raconté sa journée n'a jamais
pris des photos d'elle elle était dans
l'avion avec nous je suis désolé ça a
changé et pas de changer depuis 10 15
ans will a changé pas en bien et je
remarque que je suis le seul à subir ce
traitement absolument infâme ils savent
jouer et j'aimerais bien faire jouer bah
oui c'est sûr que ça m'a affecté wall
évidemment d'abord c'est une détruit ma
vie privée et deuxièmement surtout oui
mais on déshabille j'ai aussi je me
fiche bien que les jeunes la vierge qui
arias mais des journalistes de toulon où
il y avait aucun journaliste on m'a dit
non on m'a pris au téléobjectif et je
pense qu'il ya une action politique
derrière on veut me détruire parce que
je fais peur à certains alors voilà
c'est ça alors c'est ce que dirait que
c'est moins voilà qui fait peur à ses
petites pancartes les chiris que c'est
un acharnement va dans l'est on va voir
les ud et on va voir aussi ce qui est ce
qu a écrit dedans sarah à la deuxième
femme de sadi dans public donc c'est
vous maël en plus vous êtes alors miles
vous êtes responsable de l'un des infos
à public 1 c'est ça voilà tout ce qu'il
faut c'est miles voilà les chefs
d'informations mais qu'en tout cas merci
d'être là c'est vrai que comme dit
l'autre la deuxième femme de sa vie mais
parce que eric zemmour est mariée tout
simplement depuis 35 ans avec une
avocate milieu sportif est-ce que
c'était pour sa femme c'est un enfer la
peau je ne suis pas sûr qu'elle soit
absolument dans le brouillard autour de
ces mêmes et vous savez et le pire dans
ces cas là je vous dis voilà moi je n'ai
pas de leçon mais on n'est pas là pour
faire la place le procès de la prospère
mais c'est vrai que c'est plus c'est
aussi l'entourage en dépit on est eric
zemmour lui-même prône le libertinage
prenez l'échangisme dans son centre
était là le premier sexe
donc voilà je pense que sa femme avec
certaines clés sur alors il a fait la
une des trois journaux donc ce week-end
sarah sa conseillère très particulière
et c'est vrai qu'ils disent bien l'âge
parce qu'il ya soixante trois ans elle
en a 28 alors lui crie au complot
politique c'est ça est ce que pour vous
vous voyez un complot politique derrière
où vous quand vous faites votre nom vous
dit pas absolument pas nous on fait
notre ruine et on parle d'eric zemmour
pas parce qu'un ça va mais là ça va bien
depuis toujours là on appelait encore
les la pauvreté en tout cas quand on
parle d'un acharnement nous pour c'est
la première fois qu'on frime croyais et
eric zemmour ça ça avance a non
seulement le savait on l'espère vous
savez dit non mais c'est important dans
cette rue si vous êtes
intéressé personne c'est oui on vous
avait pas maître bernard montiel ans ma
main dans la main des comptes
à leurs voix à 12h23
nerfs quand même et donc voilà donc
c'est vrai mais pour vous il ya pas de
commande ou de gens qui n'auront sur sa
tête et des paparazzi est ce qu a dit
parce que sk des paparazzi qui sont
derrière lui enfin panne de la part du
public oui en revanche oui à des
paparazzi par exemple le photographe qui
l'a suivi pour paris match est un
paradis c'est ça il est alors au départ
comme on l'a dit au départ et je le
redis aux téléspectateurs c'est vrai que
la une de paris match d'ailleurs pourvoi
la une de paris match pour moi eric
zemmour ou par eric zemmour elle est
inadmissible on va pas se mentir et je
vous le dis je devais faire la une de
paris match je la refuse un amour et ça
oui je la refuse bon oui oui c'est ça
pour moi même pour l'image de la femme
judy c'est inadmissible ah oui parce
qu'il soit là qu'on consomme on s'en
fout on semble pas la photo je vous le
dis je suis pas d'accord
non mais elle est dégradante pour pour
la pauvre pour l'image de la femme je
suis désolé pour ça et même de l'homme
regardez c'est dégradant pour lui non
mais non encore yaya de regard voilà je
trouves tu peux te dire qu'ils ont
protégé la finit en montre on passe en
voilà donc prêt chante du coup j'avais
refusé la une l'animal était bien
savourer je le ferai pas et je ferai la
une du figaro bague voilà à la basse et
bien voilà produira non mais c'est vrai
que voilà pas le même délire non mais ce
que je vous dis je reste que si c'est
inadmissible et quand la direction
change rien on verra ce qu'on fera mais
pour l'instant voilà c'est un torchon
oui juste pour vous répondre madame avec
avec tout le respect que j'ai ce que
vous dites est faux c'est à dire que il
ya évidemment pas de vous mais
globalement des commandes je parlais de
public cyril il ya des commandes
orchestré pour faire tomber eric zemmour
on va dire les choses et bien entendu un
peu vous expliquer ça c'est intéressant
vient de téléphoner à deux choses il ya
deux choses il ya les paparazzi qui eux
bossent comme pour vous en freelance et
il arrive hippisme pendant des semaines
et mourra la place partout et il arrive
devant les journaux et 10g ça et après
ils font monter les enchères et c'est le
plus offrant qui cale et ça c'est la
première chose là c'est pas un complot
mais dieu sait que je suis pas proche
des idées de zemmour mais c'est vrai que
notamment au gouvernement
certains ont juré d'avoir sa tête on va
pas dire le contraire et pour avoir la
tête de zemmour vous préparer des
dossiers qui fait ça bakou gouvernement
c'est à dire que y'a pas une officine ya
un cabinet noir mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
plein de gens qui travaillent sur
zemmour est globalement le point faible
potentiel je fais attention à ce que je
dis de zemmour ce sont les femmes donc
du coup il ya plein de gens qui
travaillent en ce moment pour faire
tomber zemmour au moment où il va se
déclarer il ya des dossiers sur zemmour
qui vont sortir ça c'est une réalité
cyril on va dire le contraire alors la
versatile qui ont deux succès dont un
peu de sueur sur tous les politiques qui
ont du succès sur lui particulièrement
maintenant je vais
je vais dire ce qui est dit dans
l'article de public ces soutiens qu'il
imagine déjà les ébauches d'arrache-pied
sur sa possible campagne ses détracteurs
eux sont déjà au lit préparant leur
prochaine offensive seuls restent sahara
ces jeux plonger dans ceux de la
nouvelle star des identitaires leur
éclat de rire pourrait bien réveiller
les voisins qu'importe ils sont habitués
à croiser régulièrement le polémiste
dans l'immeuble de la jeune femme ce
dernier a ses habitudes composant le
code d'entrée de sa conseillère son
réfléchir à l'horlogerie il paraît qu'il
ya un truc chez les papas à 10 et
d'après ce que paul c'est que vous
regardez si le mec connaît le code
d'entrée en fait servi de la porte est
vrai que sa femme est bien sûr ça fait
une fernand 10 évident ouais c'est ça
rentre le soir chez sarah knafo qui tape
le code de tête et qu'il en ressort en
ces temps changé pour aller dîner c'est
une collaboration extrêmement proches
qui dépasse le cadre professionnel enfin
c'est à lui envoyer un texto et
peut-être chiffres avant qu'il a retenu
les quatre chiffres c'est pas non plus
me sentir humains drew tâte chiffres
mais oui mais bon voilà en tout cas
[Rires]
pas question qu'il faut se poser c'est
qu'aujourd'hui est ce qu'une affaire
d'infidélité supposé suffit à faire
tomber un homme politique moi je pense
que la réponse est non il ya quelques
années oui ça aurait choqué énormément
de monde et ça l'aurait grillé
aujourd'hui alors où il ya des dossiers
toutes les semaines qui sortent sur
toutes les personnalités bas tout le
monde s'en fout et moi dans les
dernières apparitions publiques d'eric
zemmour que ce soit sur le débat sur sud
radio ce matin j'ai pas vu un homme
abattu j'ai vu un homme qui répondait
aux questions qu'on lui posait mais qui
s'en foutait un peu et je pense que les
gens s'y intéressent et 100 mais ça ne
va pas de grille en poly d'angola faire
bien sûr on chante alors dans l'article
parle aussi de la femme d'eric zemmour
marier avec lui depuis près de 40 ans
dont dix passés au courant de quoi que
ce soit ou ce qu'elle en pense on dit de
son côté mylène l'épousé d'éric et la
mère de ses trois enfants préfèrent
rester discrètes jamais elle n'a apporté
son soutien à son mari alors qu'au
tribunal lorsqu il comparaissait pour
incitation à la haine est-ce que voilà
elle a rien qu'on est ce que quelqu'un a
fait 13 morts en novembre on verra si sa
femme est là et encore il a connu mais
est ce que quand vous sortez d'une comme
ça pour nos téléspectateurs est
interdite comme ça est-ce que vous
enquêtez un petit peu sur la famille
pour savoir s'il va leur faire de la
peine ou pas du tout la vérité ou alors
pour tout vous dire là là dans ce cas la
non danse que les enfants sont grands et
que est donc encore une fois eric
zemmour lui même prendre le libertinage
il part d'échangisme il a des termes
pour décrire la femme et les relations
entre une femme assez dur
c'est choquant pour beaucoup dans
d'autres situations oui on s'interroge
quand il ya des enfants en bas âge alors
n'avait pas l'air d'accord n'est pas
d'accord alors vous êtes le président de
la génération z ils attaqueront la
génération z c'est un mouvement de
jeunes qui appelle à la candidature
d'eric zemmour à l'élection présentielle
je crois que c'est des jeunes qu'ils
étaient les aident à n'avoir
rien à voir mais ça paye stanislas
décalage tennis et j'ai 22 ans ouais
c'est beau et jalousie non voyons direct
et avancer
enfin pas tout jeune mais qu'est ce qui
te plaît chez eric zemmour toi tu es
tout justement qu'elles ne fussent
politique et c'est pour ça que nous
apprenons à [ __ ]
des coups
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais le temps mais justement ce team
estime t il fit ses clients la campagne
qui arrivent pour les six prochains mois
et on est en train de passer de la
presse people en fait eric zemmour il
fait de la politique on va en parler on
se dira prêt mais je sais bien mais là
c'est si on voulait faire de la
politique parce qu'eric zemmour voulait
faire de la télé réalité au delà du
people il aurait fait les ont gelé
marseille afin d'avertir donc mais la
politique a commencé avec mme affoué
politique c'est sa collaboratrice et
c'est une raison pour les afficher bah
pourquoi pas ben bongo badauds mais ce
qui est normal mais là une décision
finale sur sa maîtresse à nu la trouve
ça nul je trouve ça aucun intérêt c'est
intérieur personne je pense c'est quand
même et ça cartonne face on en parle ici
par se fait donc sous marine en effet
lui qui payeront plus que j'ai vu la
meute et j'ai vu ce qu'il avait écrit un
peu à l'intérieur de voici et public
mais c'est ridicule
les légions dont tous des photos mais
j'ai jamais vu ça cd oui pense à son
repas aux chandelles mais vous à quel
moment c'est ce type en ce moment là
qu'une mince et d'assassinats qui dit
universel
si ce que disent tous les gens et emma
elle vous venez de le dire c'est que
vous dites ils se cachent pas que ça
veut dire ça ne se cache pas par exemple
dire qu'il savait et il y en a qui dit
aussi ça peut être une libération pour
lui voilà et
saas et on passe à autre ça je suis pas
dans dans son couvent dans sa chambre
donc j'ai besoin libyen des souffrances
parce que vu ce que vous faites non loin
d'eux ans
mais bon cela nous on va sur stan s'il
vous plaît vous d'accord
[Rires]
pour moi
honnêtement je pense que votre eric
zemmour est pas du tout cru dans quoi
parce que quand on se prétend hommes
politiques alors à moi donc je peux pas
faire le ps par la morale mais enfin
quand même monde est à minima un peu il
serait pas irréprochable c'est quoi
l'histoire non non non il avait alors
fait alors excusez-moi zambie titre le
dacquois en quoi bah si les sites et
quoi mans il a une double vie ce qui
semble être le cas jusqu'où les sms que
les français qui vont voter pour lui
rhône ont quelque chose à [ __ ] moi moi
c'est ça la question que j'ai offert à
néant on va regarder ça veut dire c'est
que c'est pas le remède est ce que ça va
influencer leur vote pour lui ou pas se
passe pas du tout non mais c'est aussi
pour ça que je pense pas toujours un
complot politique il va c'est simple il
est ce qu'il allait me après kick est la
sienne effectivement il ya apparemment
une double vie mais ça n'aura aucune
incidence sur le vote des gens sachent
poule alors bernard montiel non moi je
crois que la vraie question qu'on peut
se poser c'est qui profite le crime en
quelque sorte je suis pas sûr en réalité
gilles que ça ne profite pas que ça ne
profite pas du tout au gouvernement le
gouvernement ça les intéresse beaucoup
qu'il y ait un eric zemmour comme ça que
ça ferait un bordel dans le jeu
électoral ça fait descendre marine le
pen ça fait vaguement monter la droite
donc là on va se retrouver et vous allez
être très surpris et ne croyez pas que
ça vient du gouvernement faisant mais si
marie jo apporte ses connaissances macro
si marine le pen baisse marine le pen
baisse mécaniquement s'intéresse à mâcon
le mais la meilleure alliée des macros
en cas de second tour
c'est marine le pen il a besoin de
marine le pen vous pensez que c'est une
manoeuvre politique ah ben on veut
scientifique ne s'arrange pas la macro
ni par appétit seul point d'entrée que
ça va voir
[Rires]
lt gbagbo c'est magnifique chant
insultant
oui alors oui
c'est vrai on sort du caveau de bezons
public et voici ils sont entièrement
dans le rôle défense qu'ils ont toujours
fait donc là il ya pas de soucis même
s'ils s'intéressent plus aux politiques
qu'autrefois en revanche de la bourrine
match oui il ya une idée ils ont une
idée derrière la tête et oui je pense
qu'ils allaient un complot pour à m
amour mais notamment dans les milieux à
kampala macro ni les milliers
républicain je pensais pas vraiment
intérêt à faire tomber eric zemmour et
c'est eux qui le haïssent et c'est eux
qui le voit émerger vous remarquerez
attaques de zemmour ça ne va que contre
les jambes de dlr bertrand jamais contre
la macro ni jamais et oui alors
non mais moi je moi je je me demande si
ça peut pas profiter aux médias en eux
mêmes parce qu'on sait qu'eric zemmour
tout ce que fait réglé ça cartonnait
droit les audiences qu'il a fait sur les
débats est-ce que c'est pas la presse
qui se dit ou d'un mois je vous poserai
pas parce que justement ce faire il
ya dix ans on sera sportivement non non
on va faire comment met on va parler des
mots parce que c'est un bon voilà c'est
ça
intéresse le public sait pas forcément
politiques ce n'est pas être que people
aussi c'est non mais c'est cela oui
bonjour c'est pas du tout